Diese Untertitel
sind live produziert.
sub1
Guten Abend.
sub2
Deutschland auf der Suche
nach der richtigen Therapie.
sub3
Die bisherige hat noch nicht
wirklich angeschlagen.
sub4
Dazu kommt: Die Symptome sind klar,
sub5
die exakten Ursachen
zunehmend umstritten.
sub6
Und, was das ganze
noch mal komplizierter macht:
sub7
Es doktern gleich mehrere Koryphäen
daran herum.
sub8
Das ist die Lage nach drei Wochen
Teil-Shutdown im November.
sub9
Die Neuinfektionen
explodieren nicht mehr,
sub10
aber sie gehen auch nicht wirklich
nachhaltig zurück.
sub11
Warum? Das ist die große Frage.
sub12
Heute haben die Minister-
präsident*innen der Bundesländer
sub13
untereinander konferiert.
sub14
Sie wollen, müssen für kommende Woche
ein Konzept fertig haben,
sub15
mit welchen Regeln
dieses Land in den Dezember geht,
sub16
Richtung Weihnachten und Silvester.
sub17
Eines scheint heute bereits klar:
Einfacher wird es nicht.
sub18
Mathis Feldhoff berichtet.
sub19
Hier werden sie derzeit gesammelt,
sub20
all die Vorschläge aus den Ländern
mit einem V am Anfang.
sub21
V wie Verbote, Verlängerung
oder Verschärfung.
sub22
Im Dienstsitz des Berliner
Bürgermeisters entsteht das Papier,
sub23
das man der Kanzlerin vorlegt.
sub24
Verlängern scheint schon Konsens,
Verschärfen vielleicht auch.
sub25
Es gibt keine Anlass
zu einer Entwarnung,
sub26
auch keine Teilentwarnung.
sub27
Wir müssen uns leider
mit der Tatsache vertraut machen,
sub28
dass der Lockdown verlängert wird.
sub29
Deutschlandweit sind die Zahlen
noch zu hoch.
sub30
Das hat auch damit zu tun,
dass wir wirklich Hotspots haben,
sub31
die ganz ganz hohe Inzidenzen haben,
sub32
wo dieser November-Shutdown
nicht ausreicht.
sub33
Und vor allem dort muss es
zu schärferen Regeln kommen.
sub34
Rund 3 km sind es zu dem Ort, an dem
am Mittwoch wieder gefeilscht wird.
sub35
3 km durch Berlin,
von den Ländern zum Bund.
sub36
Von den Ministerpräsidenten, die
letzte Woche noch gezögert haben,
sub37
zur Kanzlerin,
die längst zu Härterem bereit war.
sub38
Im Kanzleramt wartet man jetzt,
sub39
sollen doch die Bundesländer
mal was vorschlagen.
sub40
Am Mittwoch soll es
sub41
eine geschlossene,
eine gemeinsame Antwort geben.
sub42
Ganz zufrieden
wirkt die Bundesregierung
sub43
aber heute noch nicht.
sub44
Tatsache ist, dass wir noch nicht
so weit sind,
sub45
wie wir gerne gekommen wären
durch die Kontaktbeschränkungen.
sub46
Und deshalb ahnt ja auch jeder, dass
es noch Verlängerungen geben muss.
sub47
Doch wie lange die Verlängerung
tatsächlich dauern soll,
sub48
wie lange Restaurants und Bars
noch geschlossen bleiben, ist offen.
sub49
Die Maskenpflicht in Schulen
sub50
soll möglicherweise auf alle
Altersklassen ausgeweitet werden.
sub51
Und der Präsenzunterricht
in den Oberstufen
sub52
und Berufsschulen
könnte reduziert werden.
sub53
Kontaktbeschränkung
als Allheilmittel.
sub54
Und dennoch wirkt es nur
wie eine Bekämpfung der Symptome.
sub55
Aktuell ist das Infektionsgeschehen
sehr diffus, viele Menschen
sub56
wissen gar nicht,
wo sie sich angesteckt haben.
sub57
Und dementsprechend
ist es schwierig,
sub58
ganz gezielt Maßnahmen zu ergreifen,
sub59
um diese speziellen Schritte
oder Situationen zu unterbinden.
sub60
Längst verläuft die Konfliktlinie
nicht mehr zwischen Parteien
sub61
oder Koalitionen, zwischen Bund
und Ländern,
sub62
sondern zwischen den Bundesländern
mit hohen Fallzahlen
sub63
und denjenigen mit weniger.
sub64
Es wäre wünschenswert,
sub65
wenn eine regionale Differenzierung
möglich wäre.
sub66
Es gibt Regionen im Nordosten,
wo das Pandemiegeschehen
sub67
völlig anders ist
als in Bayern beispielsweise.
sub68
Härter, länger, differenzierter.
sub69
Die Stichworte für die Debatte
am Mittwoch sind gesetzt.
sub70
Dass es dadurch verständlicher
und nachvollziehbarer wird,
sub71
müssen Bund und Länder
jetzt noch beweisen.
sub72
Härter, länger, differenzierter -
sub73
Berlins Regierender Bürgermeister
Michael Müller, SPD,
sub74
ist der Vorsitzende
der Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz.
sub75
Sie haben die Aufgabe,
sub76
einen gemeinsamen Beschluss
vorzubereiten.
sub77
Alle Details am Mittwoch -
kann man zusammenfassend sagen,
sub78
die Maßnahmen gehen weiter
und werden eher verschärft?
sub79
Wir wissen alle, dass wir noch mehr
tun müssen.
sub80
Wir haben schon viel erreicht.
sub81
Die Maßnahmen vom November haben
schon Wirkung gezeigt.
sub82
Aber wir wissen, bist zu der Phase,
wo ein Impfstoff zur Verfügung
sub83
steht, haben wir noch viel zu tun.
sub84
Das eint uns, dass wir gerade bei
den Themen, die angesprochen wurden,
sub85
wir noch keine Lockerungen zulassen
können.
sub86
Also Theater, Sporthallen usw.
bleiben zu.
sub87
Die Kontaktbeschränkungen werden
verschärft?
sub88
Es spielt eine Rolle, dass wir
regional angepasst vorgehen wollen.
sub89
Wir haben bundesweit ein Problem.
sub90
Nirgendwo sind die Zahlen wirklich
gut.
sub91
Aber in einigen Regionen sind sie
besser als woanders.
sub92
Dass man dann gegebenenfalls bei
einer weiterhin positiven
sub93
Entwicklung früher Dinge möglich
machen kann, als in anderen
sub94
Ländern,
sub95
ist eine Überlegung, die
festgehalten wurde.
sub96
Lassen Sie uns über den Zeitrahmen
reden.
sub97
Geht das ganze jetzt über
Weihnachten hinaus?
sub98
Gilt es für den gesamten Winter?
sub99
Oder bleibt es bei der Salamitaktik?
sub100
Nein, das wollten wir ja auch
verhindern.
sub101
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen mit
fast allen Ministerpräsidenten
sub102
gesprochen.
sub103
Wir haben einen ständigen Austausch.
sub104
Wir wollen in Phasen diverse
Schritte festhalten.
sub105
Bis zur Weihnachtszeit, dann über
die Weihnachtszeit und Silvester
sub106
hinaus.
sub107
Genau das von Woche zu Woche neu
entscheiden müssen, zu neuen
sub108
Maßnahmen kommen müssen, wollen wir
alle vermeiden.
sub109
Dafür gibt es einen Vorschlag, der
längerfristig ist.
sub110
Jetzt bleibt das Grundproblem.
sub111
Wir wissen nicht genau, warum die
Zahlen nicht wirklich runtergehen.
sub112
Haben Sie den Eindruck, sie haben
für alle Entscheidungen
sub113
genügend Datenbasis?
sub114
Es gibt Erkenntnisse und es
verdichten sich Dinge,
sub115
wo man sieht, dass Kontakte eine
große Rolle spielen.
sub116
Es ist bestimmt nicht das einzige,
man kann es auch nicht auf eine
sub117
einzige Gruppe begrenzen.
sub118
Aber bestimmte Dynamiken werden von
größeren Gruppen ausgelöst.
sub119
Man kann aus allem Rückschlüsse
ziehen.
sub120
Dort, wo jüngere Menschen
zusammenkommen,
sub121
dort muss man besonders auf ältere
achten.
sub122
Diese erkranken schwerer.
sub123
Daraus ergibt sich der Maßnahmenmix.
sub124
Gezielt an bestimmten Stellen.
sub125
Wenn wir diesen teilweisen Lockdown
vergleichen mit dem im Frühjahr,
sub126
gibt es viele Faktoren, die
unterschiedlich sind.
sub127
Ein wichtiger sind die Schulen.
sub128
Die waren im Frühjahr geschlossen.
sub129
Sie sollen jetzt offenbleiben.
sub130
An Studien sieht man, dass das
Infektionsgeschehen stärker ist, als
sub131
gedacht,
sub132
beziehen sie dann die Schulen
mit ein?
sub133
Da muss man auch reagieren.
sub134
In den Kitas und Grundschulen gibt
es wenig Infektionen.
sub135
Je älter die Kinder werden, desto
mehr spielen die Erkrankungen eine
sub136
Rolle.
sub137
Dass man dort unterscheidet und
sagt, wir wollen bei den kleinen
sub138
anders vorgehen.
sub139
Ältere Kinder können mit einer
Schulschließung anders umgehen.
sub140
Armin Laschet hat gesagt, es wird
das härteste Weihnachten, das
sub141
Nachkriegsgenerationen
je erlebt haben.
sub142
Hat er recht?
sub143
Ich kann mich einer solchen Rhetorik
nicht anschließen.
sub144
Das ist natürlich eine bedrückende
Situation, die sich niemand
sub145
gewünscht hat.
sub146
Aber man muss auch sehen, was wir
erreicht haben.
sub147
Im internationalen Vergleich sind
wir mit unserem Weg, auch mal
sub148
nachzusteuern,
sub149
sehr gut gefahren.
sub150
Ich finde, das rechtfertigt auch,
dass wir gemeinsam die ein oder
sub151
anderen Einschränkung auch über
Weihnachten ertragen.
sub152
Mit neuen und längeren Beschränkungen
kommt auch die Frage:
sub153
Wie hilft man denen,
sub154
die jetzt bereits vor dem
wirtschaftlichen Abgrund stehen.
sub155
Kommen nach den "November-Hilfen"
die Dezember Hilfen?
sub156
Martin Niessen zeigt, dass all das
bei weitem nicht so einfach ist
sub157
und dass es nicht nur Restaurants,
Theater und Weihnachtsmärkte trifft,
sub158
sondern viel mehr Branchen,
die dahinter stehen,
sub159
zigtausende überall in diesem Land.
sub160
Nichts dreht sich,
nichts bewegt sich.
sub161
In der Hammonia Wäscherei in Hamburg
stehen die Maschinen still.
sub162
Mit dem Teil-Shutdown bricht dem
sub163
auf Hotel- und Gastronomiewäsche
spezialisierten Familienunternehmen
sub164
die Geschäftsgrundlage weg.
sub165
Von 125 Tonnen Bettwäsche,
Handtüchern,
sub166
Tischdecken und Servietten
pro Woche sind noch zehn übrig.
sub167
Zu wenig für 70 Angestellte.
sub168
Wir arbeiten momentan
einen halben Tag in der Woche,
sub169
um diese zehn Tonnen zu bearbeiten.
sub170
Den Rest der Zeit
sind alle in Kurzarbeit.
sub171
Weithin sichtbares Symbol des
Stillstands: die Elbphilharmonie.
sub172
Keine Konzerte,
keine Touristenströme,
sub173
das spüren sie im Hotel
der Elphi deutlich.
sub174
Mit den wenigen Geschäftsreisenden
sub175
liegt die Auslastung
im einstelligen Prozentbereich
sub176
bei nahezu
gleichbleibenden Fixkosten.
sub177
Wo es geht, werden v.a. externe
Dienstleistungen heruntergefahren.
sub178
Und das sind
in einem Hotelbetrieb nicht wenige.
sub179
Dazu gehören die Zimmerreinigung,
Wäschereien, Floristik,
sub180
Veranstaltungstechnik
und nicht zuletzt auch
sub181
unsere Lebensmittel- und
Getränkehändler, die uns beliefern.
sub182
Im Frischeparadies
im Hamburger Hafen etwa
sub183
machen Hotel- und
Restaurantküchen normalerweise
sub184
70 % des Umsatzes aus.
sub185
Doch das bisschen
Take-Away-Geschäft,
sub186
mit dem sich die Gastronomie
über Wasser zu halten versucht,
sub187
füllt die Lücken in den
Auftragsbüchern nicht ansatzweise.
sub188
Auch hier sind drei Viertel
der Belegschaft in Kurzarbeit.
sub189
Wir haben seit dem neuen Lockdown
so gut wie nichts mehr zu tun.
sub190
Wenn wir früher vier Tonnen
am Tag bewegt haben,
sub191
sind es jetzt
vielleicht noch 250 Kilo.
sub192
Und die Aufträge sind sehr klein,
sub193
weil natürlich auch unsere
Gastronomen und Hotels
sub194
alle deutlich weniger,
bzw. gar nichts mehr zu haben.
sub195
Die Schließungen im Hotel- und Gast-
gewerbe erzeugen eine Kettenreaktion
sub196
mit erheblichen
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Folgen.
sub197
Die Gastronomie erwirtschaftet
in Deutschland
sub198
ca. 45 Mrd. Euro pro Jahr.
sub199
Auf jeden einzelnen Euro kommen
noch einmal fast 90 Cent dazu,
sub200
die in Zulieferbranchen,
also indirekt produziert werden.
sub201
Wo der Zulieferer nur Geschäft hat,
weil die Gastronomie Nachfrage hat,
sub202
wo der Mitarbeiter der Gastronomie
anderswo Nachfrage erzeugt
sub203
und so die Wirtschaft
in Gang bringt.
sub204
Wirtschaftlicher Schaden des
erneuten Stillstands in der Branche:
sub205
rund 7,5 Mrd. Euro.
sub206
Die zugesagte Novemberhilfe
der Bundesregierung
sub207
rettet die Hammonia Wäscherei
über den Monat.
sub208
Wird der Teil-Shutdown
ohne weitere Hilfen verlängert,
sub209
droht aus dem Schaden
ein Totalschaden zu werden.
sub210
Die Toten dieser Pandemie erscheinen
als Zahlen in den Nachrichten,
sub211
auch bei uns hier.
sub212
Welche Schicksale dahinter stehen,
sub213
was all das für
die Hinterbliebenen bedeutet,
sub214
darüber sagen die Zahlen nichts.
sub215
Wichtig beim Abschiednehmen
sind Rituale.
sub216
Unser erster Reflex:
den anderen in den Arm nehmen.
sub217
Berührungen helfen
oft mehr als Worte.
sub218
Und sie fehlen jetzt
noch mal ganz besonders
sub219
und gerade denen, die trauern müssen
in traurigen Zeiten,
sub220
wie Sibylle Bassler zeigt.
sub221
Immer wieder gäbe es Momente,
sagt Sabine Gassner,
sub222
da sei ihr der Großvater sehr nahe.
sub223
Bilder tauchen dann von ihm auf:
ein lebensfroher Mensch,
sub224
der sich in seinem Seniorenheim
aufgehoben fühlt.
sub225
Bis Anfang April
die Nachricht kommt:
sub226
Der 83-Jährige
hat sich mit Corona infiziert.
sub227
Dann hat sich der Zustand
sehr schnell verschlechtert,
sub228
und er ist dann auch verstorben,
Mitte April.
sub229
Es ist sehr schwer damit umzugehen,
sub230
dass man sich nicht verabschieden
konnte, vorher, von dem Erkrankten.
sub231
Statt Abschied nehmen zu können,
ist da nur Leere.
sub232
Dann trifft sie eine zweite
Hiobsbotschaft.
sub233
Kurz darauf hat sich auch mein
Schwiegervater in spe angesteckt
sub234
und ist dann daran auch verstorben.
sub235
Das heißt, wir haben gleich zwei Mal
sub236
so einen schlimmsten Ausgang
der Krankheit miterleben müssen.
sub237
Sterben, Tod, Trauer.
sub238
Das Leid verlangt von Angehörigen
und Schwerkranken
sub239
schier Unvorstellbares.
sub240
Gerade zu Beginn der Pandemie,
sub241
als Krankenhäuser und Altenheime
für die Außenwelt verschlossen sind.
sub242
Es gibt keinen Zuspruch, keine
Umarmung, keinen Abschiedskuss.
sub243
Die Vorstellung, den Sterbenden
alleingelassen zu haben,
sub244
ist bedrückend.
sub245
Weil man nicht nur in der Stunde
des Todes nicht dabei sein konnte,
sub246
sondern die ganzen Wochen davor
schon nicht.
sub247
Da steckt sehr viel Schuldgefühl
in den Angehörigen drin,
sub248
dass sie sagen, ich bin meiner
Verpflichtung als Angehöriger
sub249
nicht nachgekommen.
sub250
Und da muss man sie befreien
und ihnen sagen,
sub251
du hast keine Fehler gemacht.
sub252
Corona habe die Trauerkultur
verändert, so Schießler.
sub253
Für alle, deren Angehörige
in diesen Zeiten versterben.
sub254
Der Tod findet im Kleinen statt.
sub255
Die Rituale des Abschieds
sind eingeschränkt:
sub256
eine offene Aufbahrung
nicht möglich,
sub257
Trauergottesdienste selten.
sub258
Die Zahl der Trauergäste reduziert.
sub259
Es sind zehn bis 15 Leute,
je nach Möglichkeit,
sub260
je nach Größe des Friedhofs und der
Trauerhalle und die die kommen,
sub261
die sind ganz bewusst dabei.
sub262
Auch der Großvater von Sabine
und ihrer Schwester Julia
sub263
wird im engsten Kreis beerdigt.
sub264
Statt Nähe Abstand,
ein schmerzliches Erlebnis.
sub265
Umso mehr trifft es sie, wenn
Menschen Corona verleugnen.
sub266
Auch deshalb sei es ihr wichtig,
über ihre Trauer zu sprechen.
sub267
Dass die Leute sehen,
hinter dieser Zahl der Toten
sub268
da stecken auch echte Menschen,
echte Angehörige und echtes Leid.
sub269
Für die Statistik ist er einer
der über 14.000 Menschen,
sub270
die bisher in Deutschland
durch Covid-19 gestorben sind.
sub271
Für sie ist es ihr Großvater.
sub272
Anteil nehmen,
ohne dabei sein zu können.
sub273
Ende ohne Abschied -
sub274
was uns Corona kostet,
ist kaum noch fassbar.
sub275
Und das gilt auch im ganz
schnöden, rein finanziellen Sinn.
sub276
Erstens, weil die Zahlen
so gigantisch sind.
sub277
Und zweitens, weil niemand wirklich
sagen kann, ob all das Geld reicht.
sub278
Die Neuverschuldung des Bundes
im kommenden Jahr jedenfalls
sub279
muss jetzt neu gerechnet werden.
sub280
Bundesfinanzminister Scholz
sub281
plant laut Medienberichten
160 Mrd. Euro an neuen Schulden ein
sub282
und damit über 60 Mrd. mehr
als bisher bekannt.
sub283
Dafür gebe es v.a. zwei Gründe:
sub284
Zum einen stiegen die Kosten
für Wirtschaftshilfen
sub285
im Zuge der Corona-Krise.
sub286
Zum anderen würden Ausgaben
ins kommende Jahr verschoben.
sub287
Scholz selbst sagte,
für 2020/21 zusammengenommen
sub288
werde der Korridor
ungefähr der gleiche bleiben.
sub289
Eine gerechte Verteilung
von Corona-Impfstoffen,
sub290
die Unterstützung ärmerer Länder
und den Kampf gegen den Klimawandel -
sub291
das schreiben sich die G20-Staaten
auf die Fahne
sub292
in der Abschlusserklärung
nach ihrem Videogipfel.
sub293
Wie konkrete Maßnahmen aussehen
und finanziert werden sollen,
sub294
ließen die Teilnehmer
allerdings offen.
sub295
Zuvor hatte US-Präsident Trump
seinen Videoauftritt
sub296
für eine Attacke gegen
das UN-Klimaabkommen genutzt.
sub297
Es sei unfair und ziele darauf ab,
sub298
die amerikanische Wirtschaft
zu töten, so Trump.
sub299
In Belarus war auch dieser Sonntag
ein Protestsonntag,
sub300
der 15. in Folge.
sub301
Wegen der massiven Polizeipräsenz
versammelten sich die Demonstranten
sub302
zunächst in Wohnvierteln
und Innenhöfen
sub303
und zogen von dort aus
durch die Hauptstadt Minsk.
sub304
Menschenrechtler berichten
von mehr als 300 Festnahmen.
sub305
Die Demonstranten fordern
ein Ende der Polizeigewalt,
sub306
die Freilassung
aller politischen Gefangenen
sub307
und den Rücktritt
von Präsident Lukaschenko,
sub308
dem sie Wahlbetrug vorwerfen.
sub309
In Guatemala sind Proteste gegen
den neuen Staatshaushalt eskaliert.
sub310
Hunderte Demonstranten
sub311
stürmten das Parlamentsgebäude
und legten Feuer.
sub312
Die Rede ist von
mindestens 14 Verletzten.
sub313
Insgesamt waren tausende Menschen
auf die Straße gegangen,
sub314
um den Rücktritt von
Präsident Giammattei zu fordern.
sub315
Seine Regierung hatte
einen Rekordhaushalt
sub316
durch das Parlament gebracht,
der dem Land hohe Schulden aufbürdet,
sub317
im Gesundheits- und Bildungssektor
aber Ausgaben kürzt.
sub318
Neue, breite Wählerschichten
ansprechen,
sub319
ohne die eigene Basis zu verprellen.
sub320
Einen Machtanspruch formulieren,
ohne die Überzeugungen zu verwässern,
sub321
das ist ein Drahtseilakt.
sub322
Und es ist exakt die Aufgabe,
sub323
vor der die Grünen
an diesem Wochenende standen.
sub324
Zum vierten Mal
in ihrer 40-jährigen Geschichte
sub325
hat sich die Partei
ein neues Grundsatzprogramm gegeben.
sub326
Das inhaltliche Fundament
für 100.000 Mitglieder
sub327
und die Startrampe
für den Bundestagswahlkampf.
sub328
Das alles auf einem Parteitag,
der nichts mehr hatte
sub329
von erbitterten Diskussionen
und strickenden Hitzköpfen,
sub330
dafür viel Disziplin verlangte,
nicht nur mit der Technik.
sub331
Aus Berlin, Christian von Rechenberg.
sub332
Es ist 16 Uhr,
sub333
als man im Berliner Tempodrom
plötzlich etwas hört.
sub334
Applaus, Geräusche waren rar
auf diesem Online-Parteitag.
sub335
Nun ist es da, das neue
Grundsatzprogramm der Grünen.
sub336
Mit großer Mehrheit verabschiedet,
man kann auch sagen:
sub337
fast ohne Gegenwehr.
sub338
Dieses Programm sollte nicht
die Vorsitzenden stärken,
sub339
sondern unsere Partei
dafür stark machen,
sub340
dass wir für das nächste Jahr
einen Führungsanspruch haben
sub341
und dass wir eine Grundlage
für das nächste Jahrzehnt schaffen.
sub342
Platz nehmen am Regierungstisch,
neue Wähler ranholen,
sub343
dafür mussten die Grünen
den Wohlfühlbereich verlassen,
sub344
ans Grundsätzliche gehen.
sub345
Hätte auch schiefgehen können.
sub346
Also ich glaube, es ist
in der Beobachtung ein Irrtum.
sub347
Wenn wir uns streiten, dann heißt
das nicht, dass wir uns zerstreiten.
sub348
Wenn wir uns streiten in der Partei,
sub349
dann ist das der Weg
zu neuer Geschlossenheit.
sub350
Trotzdem scheint
das Thema Klima so heikel,
sub351
dass es die Vorsitzende
lieber separat weg verhandelt.
sub352
Kompromiss mit den Hardlinern.
sub353
Zum Abstimmen blieb ja genug übrig:
sub354
Wahlalter runter auf 16,
zu Homöopathie geht man auf Abstand.
sub355
Bei der Frage
nach dem Volksentscheid aber
sub356
wird's eng und laut.
sub357
Und ich hab mich tierisch geär...
sub358
Och Mann.
sub359
Jürgen Trittin ringt erst mit
der Technik, dann mit dem Thema.
sub360
Die Antragsteller wollen
einen Wechsel des Betriebssystems.
sub361
Der Entscheidung der
frei gewählten Abgeordneten
sub362
soll Konkurrenz gemacht werden.
sub363
Ich plädiere dafür,
sub364
die Angst vor dem Wunsch
des Mitmachens und Mitbestimmens
sub365
der Menschen abzulegen.
sub366
Am Ende stimmt die Partei
knapp gegen Volksentscheide
sub367
und macht die Tür einen Spalt auf
für Genforschung.
sub368
Wieder folgt die Partei
dem Leitantrag.
sub369
Eine der wenigen Änderung
erreicht die Grüne Jugend.
sub370
Sie bekommt kostenfreie
Schulen und Kitas.
sub371
Für uns ist Bildung ein Grundrecht
sub372
und das muss für alle
kostenlos zur Verfügung stehen.
sub373
Und auch das Grundeinkommen kommt
ins Grundsatzproramm,
sub374
wenn auch nur als Leitidee.
sub375
Sie wollten es gar nicht.
sub376
Egal – ihre größte Sorge war,
angeblich, ohnehin die Technik.
sub377
Zu Recht.
sub378
Für den Spott müssen sie
nicht mehr sorgen:
sub379
Ich habe immer noch ein Problem.
sub380
Das Lob für den Mut
haben sie sich verdient.
sub381
Sie haben viel aufgelockert,
es waren tolle Videos dabei.
sub382
Das hat es leicht gemacht.
sub383
Es fehlen die Gespräche draußen
im Foyer, durch die Gänge zu gehen,
sub384
Leute zu treffen, die man
lange nicht getroffen hat.
sub385
Sie brechen also auf in die Breite.
sub386
Sicherheit, Sozialstaat,
Solidarität.
sub387
Viele Sorten Grün,
sie nennen es die Farbe der Zeit.
sub388
Das Schwarz dazwischen
ausgenommen.
sub389
Schauen wir noch auf den Sport:
sub390
Zuerst auf die zwei Sonntagsspiele
der Fußball-Bundesliga,
sub391
bei denen es
zwei Heimniederlagen gab.
sub392
Köln verlor gegen Union Berlin
mit 1:2
sub393
und Freiburg unterlag Mainz
zu Hause mit 1:3.
sub394
Markus Eisenbichler
hat den deutschen Skispringern
sub395
einen Sieg beschert,
sub396
und das schon beim ersten
Einzelweltcup der Saison.
sub397
Der 29-Jährige
sub398
sprang im polnischen Wisla
137,5 m und 134 m weit.
sub399
Damit lag er vor seinem
Teamkollegen Karl Geiger
sub400
und dem Österreicher Daniel Huber.
sub401
Nächste Weltcup-Station ist
in einer Woche das finnische Ruka.
sub402
Auch die deutschen Bob-Piloten
konnten einen Doppelsieg feiern,
sub403
beim Weltcup-Auftakt
im lettischen Sigulda.
sub404
Rekordweltmeister Francesco Friedrich
sub405
fuhr mit Anschieber
Alexander Schüller auf Platz eins
sub406
vor dem Stuttgarter Johannes Lochner,
sub407
der nach dem ersten Durchgang
noch vorne gelegen hatte.
sub408
Corona-bedingt waren in Sigulda
sub409
weniger Schlitten am Start
als üblich.
sub410
Während wir hier 2020
gegen das Fernweh kämpfen
sub411
und der Wanderausflug
in die Mittelgebirge
sub412
zunehmend als Traumreise erscheint,
machen sich andere auf:
sub413
45.000 km, einmal rund um die Erde,
und zwar so:
sub414
"Einfach mal rauskommen"
hat da gleich eine neue Bedeutung.
sub415
Das letzte ganz große Abenteuer:
sub416
Über 8.000 Menschen standen
schon auf dem Mount Everest,
sub417
fast 600 Menschen waren mal im All.
sub418
Aber erst 88 Segler haben diese
irre Wettfahrt zu Ende gebracht.
sub419
Nonstop und ohne fremde Hilfe,
sub420
ganz allein mit dem Boot,
dem Meer und der Einsamkeit.
sub421
Zum ersten Mal ist
ein Deutscher dabei,
sub422
und zwar gleich
dermaßen erfolgreich,
sub423
dass er jetzt sein Schiff
geküsst hat, weil es so toll läuft.
sub424
Hermann Valkyser hat die Bilder.
sub425
Boris Herrmann und das Meer.
sub426
Ganz allein im Segelboot
einmal um die Welt.
sub427
Erster Deutscher
bei der Vendee Globe,
sub428
der atemberaubenden
Regatta der Extreme.
sub429
Seine Rennmaschine, ein hochmodernes
segelndes Boot mit Flügeln.
sub430
Jetzt fliegen wir,
sub431
hauptsächlich mit unserem Foil
berühren wir nur noch das Wasser
sub432
und ein bisschen mit dem Heck.
sub433
Das ist virulent, kraftvoll
und in keiner Weise romantisch.
sub434
Heute vor zwei Wochen sind
in Frankreich 33 Boote gestartet,
sub435
27 Männer, sechs Frauen,
knapp 45.000 km.
sub436
Oft gesteuert vom Autopiloten,
aber Hilfe von außen ist verboten.
sub437
Inzwischen nehmen sie Kurs
aufs Kap der Guten Hoffnung,
sub438
danach droht das Südpolarmeer
sub439
mit eisigen Temperaturen
und haushohen Wellen.
sub440
In 70 bis 80 Tagen um die Welt,
alleine mit den Elementen.
sub441
Schließlich der sog.
Vorhof zur Hölle: das Kap Hoorn,
sub442
ehe sie mit bis zu 75 km/h
zurückjagen.
sub443
Etwa die Hälfte der Starter
wird es schaffen bis ins Ziel.
sub444
Ich lebe sowieso nur im Moment
und versuche, nicht dran zu denken,
sub445
wie lang dieses Rennen noch ist.
sub446
Wenn man auf die Weltkugel schaut,
krieche ich
sub447
in einem quälend langsamen
Schneckentempo über die Weltkarte.
sub448
Aber wenn ich hier
auf die Wasseroberfläche gucke,
sub449
dann geht das ziemlich fix voran.
sub450
Die ersten Stürme kamen schnell.
sub451
Anders als ein paar Mitfavoriten
sub452
hat der gebürtige Oldenburger
sie unbeschadet umschifft.
sub453
Schlafen im Höllenlärm,
immer nur wenige Minuten.
sub454
Das hat Boris Herrmann
jahrelang trainiert.
sub455
Das Vertrauen in sein Boot auch.
sub456
Tonnenschwere Lasten bewegt er
mit Hilfe von Umlenkrollen
sub457
zum Trimmen der zwei Tennisplätze
großen Segelfläche.
sub458
Sein Schiff:
vollgepackt mit Hightech,
sub459
aber finden muss er seinen Weg
durch Wind und Wetter selbst.
sub460
Etwa ein Drittel der Strecke
liegt hinter der Spitzengruppe.
sub461
Herrmann hat seine "Seaexplorer",
in der Animation das graue Bötchen,
sub462
jenseits des Äquators
auf Rang 6 manövriert
sub463
und in kaum befahrene
Meeresbereiche.
sub464
Auch im Dienst der Wissenschaft.
sub465
Diese Forschungsboje
soll Erkenntnisse
sub466
zur Erderwärmung durch CO2 liefern.
sub467
Dieses Segeln ist immer eine tolle
Metapher für die Kraft der Natur,
sub468
und diese Energie dieser Natur,
sub469
die wir auch sonst mehr noch
versuchen sollten zu nutzen.
sub470
In anderen Bereichen
der Gesellschaft,
sub471
z.B. Windenergie.
sub472
Aber warum nicht auch
segelnde Frachtschiffe?
sub473
Weite Wege, Lebensträume
und hohe Ziele
sub474
hat der 39 Jahre alte Segler
ja ohnehin bei dieser Unternehmung.
sub475
Grüße vom Vendee Globe.
sub476
Na dann, gute Reise noch,
bis mindestens Mitte Januar.
sub477
Ob das jetzt Fernweh stillen konnte?
sub478
Wahrscheinlicher ist, dass es
das gerade erst angefacht hat.
sub479
Gucken wir auf eine Novemberwoche,
die jetzt vor uns liegt.
sub480
Am Mittwoch ist klar,
sub481
wie es mit den Corona-Beschränkungen
in Deutschland weitergeht.
sub482
Darüber haben wir bereits
ausführlich berichtet heute.
sub483
Was sonst noch wichtig wird,
Jana Becker hat den Ausblick.
sub484
Ab Montag wird in Frankreich
sub485
ein ehemaliger Staatspräsident
vor Gericht stehen,
sub486
erstmals in der Geschichte
Frankreichs Fünfter Republik.
sub487
Der Vorwurf an Nicolas Sarkozy:
Korruption.
sub488
Er soll 2014 einen Staatsanwalt
in einem gegen ihn
sub489
laufenden Ermittlungsverfahren
bestochen haben.
sub490
Sarkozy drohen eine Haftstrafe
von bis zu zehn Jahren
sub491
und eine Million Euro Geldbuße.
sub492
Am Freitag wird das Rennen
um den CDU-Vorsitz
sub493
in die nächste Runde gehen:
sub494
In einer Live-Veranstaltung stellt
sich Friedrich Merz den Fragen
sub495
der CDU-Mitglieder – die Gelegen-
heit, seine Kritiker zu überzeugen.
sub496
Im Dezember sollen die nächsten
Livestream-Runden
sub497
mit Norbert Röttgen
und Armin Laschet folgen.
sub498
Ebenfalls am Freitag
sub499
freuen sich viele auf eine
Schnäppchenjagd am Black Friday.
sub500
In den USA stürmen in anderen Jahren
Schnäppchenjäger die Geschäfte,
sub501
traditionell einen Tag
nach Thanksgiving.
sub502
Mittlerweile ist der Black Friday
auch fest in Deutschland verankert.
sub503
Sowohl am Freitag selbst
als auch an den Rabatttagen davor
sub504
wird coronabedingt ein Rekord
an Online-Verkäufen erwartet.
sub505
Das Wetter gibt es sogar umsonst,
hier sind die Aussichten:
sub506
Die neue Woche startet
mit vielen Wolken und etwas Regen.
sub507
An den Küsten gibt es
einzelne Schauer.
sub508
Im Norden und am Alpenrand
wird es länger freundlich.
sub509
Danach stellt sich
ruhiges Novemberwetter ein
sub510
mit einer Mischung aus Sonne,
Wolken und zähen Nebelfeldern.
sub511
Die Temperaturen bleiben ähnlich.
sub512
Im heute journal
sub513
heißen die Aussichten nächste Woche
Marietta Slomka und Heinz Wolf.
sub514
Im Namen des ganzen Teams
danken wir für Ihr Interesse.
sub515
Ihnen einen schönen Abend noch.